[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
bruno retailleau
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
président du groupe l'est républicain
ici au sénat on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
est bonjour stéphane bonjour qui dirige
le bureau parisien du journal ouest
france
on va commencer par ce remaniement ce
nouveau gouvernement castex qui fera ses
premiers pas devant le sénat tout à
l'heure à 15 heures qu'est ce que vous
pensez vous de ce gouvernement bruno
retailleau rien tant qu'il n'a pas agi
je ne connais pas du tout jean castex
je connais son cv mais je ne vais pas
croisés donc voilà la page est blanche à
lui de l'écrire ce que j'attends
simplement du gouvernement se sont pas
des paroles des discours ce sont des
actes j'attends vraiment un changement
de politique
par exemple j'attends de monsieur
darmanin qu'il rétablisse l'ordre en
france qu'il modifie la législation pour
que l'on puisse expulser des tchétchènes
qui bénéficient du statut de réfugié et
qui sèment la violence et le désordre
j'attends aussi de monsieur dupont
moretti qui construisent des prisons
plutôt que qu'il évite comme l'a fait ça
après 10,6 après 10 heures madame bello
mais j'attends aussi de même pompili
qu'elle amène le ceta que nous ne
voulons pas voter ici au sénat elle se
dit écologiste elle alla simplement
voter l'abstention pour le ceta nous
nous voulons le combattre parce que nous
pensons que d'un point de vue écologique
du point de vue de la réciprocité de l'
équité vis-à-vis nos agriculteurs ce
n'est pas possible de demander tout l
inverse à nos agriculteurs par exemple
de monter en gamme et en même temps et
en même temps d'importer justement une
viande dont on proscrit ray les
pratiques d'élevage en france c'est pas
possible
voilà ce que j'attends concrètement un
changement de politique
donc vous avez des attentes très
concrètes sur l'action du gouvernement
mais il faisait quand même été surpris
par ce manque d'aspects notamment sa
composition
les gens qui rentrent le fac et autant
de ministres sortants qui soient
maintenues qu'est-ce que donc une
surprise aucune surprise monsieur dupont
moretti madame bachelot bien tubes mais
ça c'est l'écumé des jours ccc
la communication c'est d'ailleurs cette
sueur communication qui est en train de
tuer la politique je vais vous dire mon
analyse sur le fond c'est qu'il ya une
telle impuissance public aujourd'hui que
les hommes et les femmes politiques
surjoue la communication ils sont
d'autant plus impuissant qu'il
communique d'autant plus et voilà on est
dans le spectacle nous savions kemmel
mâcon j'ai souvent dit qu'il n'incarnait
pas qu'il interprétait parce que on sent
chez lui la dimension théâtrale
on sent chez lui l'acteur parfois le
comédien et là il s'est transformé en
metteur en scène avec des bêtes de scène
sans doute plein bachelot mais aussi
monsieur du bambin était encore une fois
tout cela c'est l'écumé des jours
ce que j'attends moi c'est des actes ce
que j'attends c'est qu'on puisse
répondre aux angoisses française et en
france nous sommes sans doute le pays le
plus pessimiste
les françaises sont sans doute le peuple
qui craint le plus l'avenir vous avez
cité trois ministres gérald darmanin
eric dupond-moretti barbara pompili
c'est les 3 dont vous allez observer
tout particulièrement l'action est ce
que est ce que vous êtes satisfait de la
nomination de gérald darmanin à
l'intérieur ce que je demande à gérald
darmanin sévèrement de rétablir l'ordre
c'est aussi de soutenir la police la
gendarmerie c'est aussi de ne pas entrer
dans la confusion dans laquelle son
prédécesseur une personnalité pour ça
peu importe
j'attends les actes moi j'ai observé et
je ne juge pas à la gueule
est-ce que ce que je ne pouvais plus à
incarner ce ministère de l'intérieur ils
avaient eu comme idée d'énormes fautes
enfin en parlant de de soupçons avérés
c'est un oxymore une contradiction en
disant pire en disant que en réalité
l'émotion devait être au dessus de la
règle juridique mais c'était une erreur
fondamentale en revanche que j'attende
monsieur darmanin c'est aussi qu'il
tranche sur ses propos qu'il a prononcé
il ya quelques années lorsque il
souhaitait en matière de communautarisme
de religion à nouveau concordat à
nouveau concordat c'est incompatible
avec le régime d'un loi de 1905 avec la
conception que nous nous faisons de la
laïcité
le concordat c'est napoléon napoléon
qu'il disait
voilà mes préfet mais évêques qu'est-ce
que il avait quelque chose à voir dans
la nomination des évêques nouveau
concordat ce sont des accommodements
avec les églises les religions non moi
j'attends pas par exemple que l'état
français se mêlent de l'islam de france
et c'est d'institutionnaliser l'islam de
france ça n'est pas sa fonction
j'attends de l'état qu'il soit
absolument neutre et qui veillent
précisément sur la laïcité à la
française sur l'autorité quand on vous
lisez jean castex dans le journal du
dimanche qui dit que la préservation de
l'ordre républicain et de la sécurité du
quotidien ne sont pas négociables
est ce que vous dites les choses ont
quand même dans le bon sens non mais ces
mollahs ont été prononcées par tous les
prédécesseurs
partout les prêts nécessaires pour vous
ça ne veut rien dire quand monsieur
dupont moretti
je lui demande solennellement de nous
dire si oui ou non il veut prolonger la
politique de madame taubira
parce que la politique de madame
belloubet était celle de benneteau bien
c'était d'abord si j'ose dire une
conception où on en voit surtout pas les
gens en prison non j'attends qu'il soit
intransigeant vis-à-vis de la
délinquance
j'attends aussi qu'il clarifie puisqu'il
a dit que son ministère était celui de
l'antiracisme lequel antiracisme
l'antiracisme à choquer ou ça vous
inquiète non il ya deux anti raciste il
y avait de l'antiracisme traditionnel on
combat le racisme au combat ce qu'ils
accordent à la couleur de peau
une sorte de valeur ça oui il faut
combattre ce racisme là mais aujourd'hui
le nouvel anti racisme il fait
profession justement de combattre le
racisme mais en réalité c'est pour
enfermer les gens les français des
citoyens dans leur couleur de peau
il ya une forme de racialisation des
rapports sociaux
il est lisse is le nouvel anti racisme
la question sociale
on en est là il veut déboulonner les
statues bien sûr jusqu à les déboulonner
la statue de victor schoelcher cas
combattu précisément l'esclavagisme qui
était un grand abolitionniste mais on
déboulonne la statue de victor
schoelcher
tout simplement parce qu'il est blanc
voyez et c'est en train de polluer y
compris la sphère la société civile
quand vous voyez une grande entreprise
comme l'oréal qui veut proscrire le mot
par exemple blanc quand vous voyez le
nuit
or times qui va désormais prétendre
puisque vous êtes journaliste grand
journal quand le quotidien ouest france
eh bien le new york times qui veut
désormais écrire le mot noir black avec
un b majuscule et le mob lights avec un
minuscule exactement avec une minuscule
ça c'est la racialisation des rapports
sociaux je n'en veux pas et le nouvel
anti racisme aujourd'hui poursuit cette
idée d'une sécession de la société voilà
l'expression exacte de d'eric
dupond-moretti c'était mon ministère sur
la sera celui de l'antiracisme et des
droits de l'homme donc ça va plutôt ça
plutôt l'air d'aller dans la dans le
sens de la première ce sont des
motivations des mauges est membre du
ministre des actes la politique ce sont
des actes avec et belle macro
aujourd'hui si les français ont de moins
en moins conscience c'est que il a
réduit la politique à des discours et
des discours qui sont souvent priant
mais il ya un énorme décalage entre les
paroles et les actes
et c'est cette dissociation qui rend les
gens totalement perdu et qu'il et
retourne dans un mouvement de colère
contre les hommes et les femmes
politiques pour finir juste sur eric
dupond-moretti jean pierre sueur le
sénateur socialiste qui était à votre
place nous disait qu'il avait demandé à
philippe bach président de la commission
des lois que eric dupond-moretti soient
auditionnés devant la commission des
lois avec tous les sénateurs est ce que
vous y êtes favorable à mais je peux
vous dire que philippe bas auditionnera
monsieur dupont moretti
bien évidemment dans les prochains jours
écoutez c'est au président de la
commission des lois qui filent pas de
fixer son calendrier avec le ministre
évidemment j'imagine que le ministre a
aussi beaucoup de choses à faire il faut
trouver un agenda mais il le fera
et puis il ya les questions précises à
lui de dia bien sûr je vous ai déjà
indiqué un centre de chose qu'est ce
qu'on fait vis-à-vis du programme de
construction des prisons
vous imaginez que madame blue bay a fait
sortir à peu près 13 mille détenus des
prisons voilà c'est une idéologie qui
nous vient du gauchisme en cela qu'elle
était à continuatrice finalement de
madame taubira mais ça c'est la
politique des mâles mac ont voulu paraît
mal macro ce que je deviens que son
premier déplacement soit à fresnes pour
vous c'est un bon signal mais ça c'est
de la communication vous avez vu tous
les ministres aller sur le terrain le
premier d'entre eux aller sur le terrain
très bien c'est une figure obligée pour
dire voyez je me préoccupe du terrain et
je fais des images voilà
le temps médiatique l'emportent sur tout
il faut que la politique se libère du
temps médiatique et pour pour terminer
avec le nouveau casting
un mot sur roselyne bachelot qui revient
au gouvernement écoutez je lui souhaite
bonne chance
je souhaite bonne chance c'est bien
connu puisque nous étions quand françois
fillon était président de la région des
pays de la loire
je t'aime moi vice président et j'ai
téléchargé la culture et elle était
chargé de l'aménagement du territoire
voilà c'est une femme de l'ouest est
heureuse une femme de l'ouest à la
culture c'est une bonne idée
poser une bâche la culture est frais
mais on met une femme elle est française
voilà et c'est un ministère qui est
difficile je pense que les qualités pour
relever le défi tout simplement là aussi
il ya aussi là il ya la création il a en
même temps le patrimoine
j'ai toujours pensé que savez je les dis
au présent république dans les ressorts
voiliers du développement économique est
aujourd'hui la france va traverser une
crise une des plus graves qu'on ait
jamais connu il faut penser au
développement économique
mais moi je peux vous dire que le
développement économique c'est aussi une
question de l'immatériel une question de
culture au sens général du terme c'est
des facultés que les hommes et les
femmes peuvent mobiliser ou une peuvent
ne pas mobiliser quand je disais que la
france était dans une grande dépression
psychologique
je pense que si on veut sortir de la
dépression économique et sociale il faut
trouver des ressorts il faut que les
français redevienne un peuple et c'est
pour ça que je me bats contre le
communautarisme contre le séparatisme
si on n'a pas ce mouvement cet élan je
pense qu'on ne pourra pas agir
matériellement donc les les ressorts de
la réussite matérielle c'est aussi de
l'immatériel est un peu de la culture
aussi je crois fondamentalement voyez
aller on va parler du premier ministre
et des réformes à venir à un mot d'abord
sur edouard philippe à ce que vous
regrettez son départ est ce qu'il est un
bon premier ministre pour vous et loire
philippe a bénéficié d'une identité
d'une image miroir c'est à dire que les
français l'apprécié d'autant plus qu'il
n'appréciait pas un certain nombre de
travers du président de république et
ses qualités sont apparus notamment en
matière de crise et pendant la crise
sanitaire et elle m'a cran et et
théâtrale lui était concret mails macron
parfois je me souviens du discours de
toulouse était peu rassurant et le
premier ministre était au contraire
plutôt apaisant c'est cette identité en
miroir mais malheureusement la crise
sanitaire a été mal géré
et malheureusement edouard philippe
était premier ministre sous l'impulsion
peut-être des mails macron mais je
considère que cette crise a été mal géré
je les dis d'ailleurs depuis le départ
et je n'ai pas changé d'avis on
regardera quelle est la mortalité par
rapport aux millions d'habitants mais
vous avez vu les masses vous avez vu le
dépistage et y compris on nous avait
promis une voir philippe 700 mille tests
par semaine on en a jamais fait plus de
300000 donc le virus il est là il
circule le virus sous une forme sans
doute atténué
peut-être à cause de la saison je n'en
sais rien je sais qu'il peut ressurgir
mais on ne combat pas le virus en
restant les bras croisés de même que
l'on ne pouvait pas le combattre
uniquement par le confinement donc oui
il avait des traits de caractère qui
pouvait si j'ose dire me touche et me
concerne et mais malheureusement il a
appliqué
évidemment nous sommes sous la vème
république la politique des mails macron
par rapport au virus que vous venez
d'évoquer le choix de jean castex
monsieur déconfinement comme premier
ministre c'est une bonne idée c'est un
bon choix non
donc ça n'apportera rien je sais écouter
on va rester comme gaulliste social non
mais le gaullisme tout le monde se
défient avez vous vu quelqu'un avait
vous reçues sur ce plateau
quelqu'un qui ne se disent pas désormais
gouly le goalie je vais vous dire le
gaullisme si on doit le caractérise et
c'est une attitude
mais c'est surtout le sursaut dans
l'épreuve eh bien nous y sommes et moi
je jugerai jean castex à sa façon de
sortir des sentiers battus parce qu'on
ne va pas reconstruire le monde de
demain c'est à dire le jour d'après avec
les vieilles recettes d'avant c'est quoi
les gars y recettes d'avant c'est tout
ce qui a coulé la france on a dit aux
français
travailler moins y'a pas de problème
vous allez vous enrichir on a dit aux
français on va pouvoir avoir des
services publics extraordinaires plus on
va dépenser plus on va dépenser
meilleures seront les services publics
vous aurez un hôpital le meilleur du
monde tous étaient faux tout s'est tu et
les mensonges
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on utilise
toujours les mêmes recettes c'est à dire
qu'on déverse l'argent on a le ségur de
la santé qu'est ce qui se passe
des milliards et vous pourrez mettre des
milliards et des milliards si vous ne
changez pas le système le système ne
s'améliorera pas oui bien sûr une
infirmière française reçoit par rapport
à la moyenne européenne 6000 euros de
moins sur son salaire
pareil les leaders il se france est
beaucoup moins bien payés que les
allemands parce qu'on se paupérise mais
faut changer le système c'est à dire que
la gouvernance de l'hôpital doit revenir
au personnel médical
vous avez 34 % de personnels
administratifs à l'hôpital en france
vous en avez vous avez 25 % en allemagne
la différence est plus de 100000 vous
rendez compte si les 100000
administratif on en remettait une partie
dans le personnage un mot sur le ségur
puisque vous en parlez les les médias
les soignants qui demandent une
revalorisation et jean castex qui a
annoncé hier qu'il allait augmenter
l'enveloppé qui était de 6 milliards à
la base qui te sera de 7,5 milliards est
ce que vous dites quand même le
gouvernement fait ce qu'il faut non non
il faut revaloriser
mais tant que vous n'aurez pas changer
le système le système fonctionne alors
isation le syst bien sûr il faudrait
valoriser mais vous déverser de l'argent
regarder l'éducation nationale quand le
système n'est pas bon plus vous ajouter
de l'argent plus le fixe le système
dysfonctionne ce que j'attends c'est de
changer radicalement les choses première
chose faire en sorte que on arrache à la
bureaucratie l'hôpital et le conte
confie la gouvernance au soigneur
première chose
j'attends aussi que l'on puisse
décentralisée par exemple les ehpad
pourquoi une double tutelle la tutelle
des départements la tutelle de l'état
non une seule tutelle les départements
la régionalisation des ars etc etc
j'ai des propositions nous avons des
propositions je les ai d'ailleurs remise
au président de la république
lorsqu'on a déjeuné avec gérard larcher
parce que moi je veux contribuer ou lors
au relèvement de mon pays mais ça n'est
certainement pas avec des milliards à
écouter la france va ressortir ruiner
voilà la vérité elle est là les français
doivent le savoir
ruinée où seront qu'est ce qu'on fait on
dépense toujours plus avec l'argent
qu'on n'a pas bien sûr qu'il faut
revaloriser le personnel soignant
mais si vous ne faites que cela vous
n'améliorait rien du tout vous l'évoquez
la décentralisation la régionalisation
aux propos de l'hôpital jean castex se
définit comme un élu local il parle
beaucoup de territoires
est ce qu'une des clés de cette sortie
de crise ou de notre avenir commun et
pas ce pas justement par par une
nouvelle donne ou d'une nouvelle
relation entre l'état et les territoires
et là
est-ce qu encore une fois ce ne sont que
des mots ou est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est l'homme c'est la bonne personne
pour mener une espèce de alors par un
big bang mais une vraie transformation
en concertation entre l'état et les élus
les et de locaux edouard philippe aussi
été maire du havre donc c'était quand
même aussi un élu local et souple dans
les négociations dans la proche on dit
que jean castex jean castex est un très
bon négociateur est ce que c'est vrai je
ne le connais pas franchement je faisais
comme je vais lui c'est à dire et ni du
bien et du mal parce que ça serait ça
serait mal de ma part voilà c'est tout
non je fais une récente particulière sur
blessure alors vous avez raison qu'est
ce qu'on a vu pendant la crise et que la
bureaucratie avait totalement paralysé
l'état et on a bien vu qu'au contraire
l'initiative locale qui parvenait à
commander justement des masques
c'était des régions les départements les
villes et d'ailleurs on allait les
terres venelles où les piquets nous les
réquisitionner sur les tarmacs donc on
voit bien que la crise qu'on traverse y
compris la crise de la démocratie
ça doit être en même temps la solution
vers plus de proximité pourquoi parce
que c'est dans la proximité qu'on
rétabli la confiance la crise française
c'est une crise de confiance en
politique mais le maire est encore un
élu dans lequel les français pour 75% en
confiance tout simplement parce que ce
qui est proche la proximité inspire
confiance et l'éloignement inspire la
défiance et on a fait tout l'inversé
avec les grandes régions les grandes
communautés de communes
on a voulu un peu tué des communes bien
nous nous voulons remettre au coeur du
village français la commune première
chose la proximité c'est aussi
l'efficacité je le disais mais c'est
aussi le lien social
qu'est-ce qui construit le lien social
aujourd'hui de moins en moins à l'école
de moins en moins si aujourd'hui et
l'archipel français de votre collègue
monsieur four qu'elle l'a montré on n'a
plus ses cadres qui pouvait être la
famille des grandes associations les
partis politiques les églises etc
mais c'est la proximité qui construit le
lien j'ai une expression et je dis
souvent le lieu c'est le lien voilà et
c'est en cela que je m'oppose à ceux qui
aiment la mondialisation qui aiment la
fluidité et la motally la mobilité je
pense qu'il faut des enracinements les
enracinements ce sont des attachements
qui sont des attachements peut-être dans
une terre mais aussi surtout surtout
dans une communauté humaine ou en piste
et je pense que cette proximité et elle
est nécessaire pour redonner un élan en
termes d'efficacité de confiance et de
lien social
il ya une réforme que jean castex semble
prêt à remettre sur la table ou en tout
cas il va discuter avec les partenaires
sociaux dans les prochaines heures c'est
la réforme des retraites est ce que pour
vous il faut la relancer cette réforme
je pense qu'on doit la relancer parce
que là encore on a les chiffres on nous
avoue 10 euros y'a pas de problème
d'argent il n'y a pas de prendre des
déficits avec la crise on va avoir 30
milliards 30 milliards d'euros de
déficit si on ne fait rien ce sont nos
aînés la retraite les pensions de nos
aînés qui seront directement menacés je
les dis dès le départ je pense que la
grande réforme systémique créé
énormément d'inégalités et il n'était
pas maîtrisée malheureusement par le
gouvernement personne ne la maîtrise est
bien donc je pense qu'on peut faire une
réforme paramétrique et on ne coupera
pas on ne coupera pas justement au recul
de l'âge
alors soit on le fait par la durée de la
cotisation c'est assez peu efficace mais
on peut le faire
soit on le fait carrément en disant
voilà on passe de 62 progressivement en
plusieurs années
à 64 ans clairement il faut relancer une
réforme des retraites n'est pas du tout
celle imaginée par emmanuel macumba
c'est clair que non mais ne parviendra
pas eu de réforme systémique pour vous
je pense qu'il faut abandonner à ford
systémique tout simplement parce qu'elle
n'était pas maîtrisée et qu'elle
générait énormément d'inégalités la
première de ces inégalités c'est le fait
de ne plus prendre justement de ne plus
calculer la retraite sur les 25
meilleures années mais sur toute une vie
les 25 meilleures années ça permettait à
celui qui partait du bas et qu'ils
progressaient progressivement de
valoriser sa retraite
donc je pense que cette mobilité sociale
et elle est importante à un mot
rapidement enfin les questions sur la
droite de stéphane sur la loi bioéthique
jean castex qui a dit hier aux
parlementaires qu'il souhaitait que la
session parlementaire soit rallongé pour
que la loi bioéthique soit adopté avant
l'été comment vous l'avez entendu cette
phrase je pense qu'il a oublié ses nains
jour elle simplement lui rappelait alors
je lui en veux pas parce qu'il n'est pas
parlementaire devra lui rappeler que le
parlement pour qu'une loi soit votée ces
deux chambres c'est l'assemblée
nationale épices et le sénat et le sénat
aura à connaître de cette loi je pense
au mois d'octobre
permettez moi simplement de vous dire
que là encore il ya un petit problème
quand même et mal macron nous a dit moi
je retire les textes qu'ils peuvent
comment dirais-je blessé la concorde
nationale
là c'est un fait
dix corps très clairement alors que on
va avoir entre un et deux millions de
chômeurs de plus alors que on a des
déficits abyssaux
on aura sans doute des désordres sociaux
qu'est ce que fait le président de la
république
voilà il remet sur le chantier la loi
bioéthique franchement est-ce que
c'était d'urgence donc pour vous il faut
la retirer ne faut pas qu'elle revienne
au sénat à l'automne ajoute non mais ça
y est elle revient l'assemblée nationale
donc je suis allé à la saga zone à
certains choix qui une fois de plus est
un choix qui contredit les propres
propos du président de république
c'est le choix de la discorde voilà
est-ce que c'est l urgence non
alors est-ce qu'on va parce que les
députés à l'époque avaient voté c'est ce
qu'on appelle les chimères c'est à dire
vous prenez un embryon anima et vous
mettez des cellules humaines et le
faisait naître et le conseil d'état
avait dit attention la zoonose c'est à
dire la transmission de maladies
entre les animaux et les hommes c'était
ce qu'était ce que l'assemblée nationale
avait déjà voté dans une première
lecture
est-ce qu'elle va revoter ce genre de
choses est ce que les français parce
qu'on dit la pma pour toutes
c'est à dire sans père et on oublie tout
le reste mais tout le reste c'est lourd
oui le une question politique sur l'état
de la droite les municipales finalement
été plutôt le premier tour a été plutôt
très bon pour les républicains le
deuxième beaucoup moins une information
chasse l'autre on parle du remaniement
on oublie ce qui s'est passé est ce que
les résultats des municipales sont de
nature à relancer les républicains
notamment pour les élections les
prochaines élections à venir jusque
jusqu'à la perspective de de la
présidentielle en 2022 ou est-ce que
vous est-ce que comment est ce que vous
voyez les choses
ce que je veux dire parce que vous parle
des municipales les municipales c'était
il ya une dizaine de jours c'est
incroyable est-ce que prison la
république d'ailleurs a tenu compte de
la leçon des municipales non je ne vois
aucune prison compte les municipales on
a bien vu que le millier mélodieux en
même temps avait été rejetée bon et le
remaniement c'est aussi un autre mini
mello je pense que oui bien sûr on a
fait des bonnes nuits
alors évidemment il ya des pertes
symboliques bordeaux ou marseille mais
partout ailleurs notamment pour les
communes de plus de 20 mille habitants
les élus républicains avec nos
partenaires nous dirigeons plus de 60%
de ces communes de plus de 20 mille
habitants donc c'est quand même une
bonne résultats en revanche comme enjeu
se traduire pour la vierge
justement je pense que je ne fais pas
partie de ceux qui pensent que la
victoire locale et préparent une
victoire nationale vaut mieux quand même
des victoires locales mais souvent sa
nouvelle r6 sur les sénatoriales de bien
sûr sur les sénatoriales c'est direct
puisque c'est une corps vous avez raison
c'est le corps des grands électeurs mais
heureusement il ya une reconstruction
qui passe par une ligne à définir qu'on
a toujours pas défini est aussi un
processus de sélection pour qu'un camp
depuis savoir un candidat qui est une
incarnation
enfin sachant condamné candidat à la
candidature il ya je constate qu'il ya
des candidats qui sont en dehors de
l'air comme xavier bertrand comme lé
pécresse il peut y en avoir à
l'intérieur de l'air comme françois
baroin comme votre serviteur ou d'autres
comment fait on pour que la primaire ne
soit pas le premier tour des
présidentielles c'est la question que je
pose et c'est la question à laquelle il
va falloir que très vite vous êtes
favorable à une primaire je suis alors
quelle forme de primaires à voir mais je
ne veux pas que le premier tour d'une
présidentielle se transforme en primaire
parce qu'alors la l'élimination est
certaine et merci beaucoup merci merci
retail est d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin